vous êtes fidèle à alain depuis combien
d'années maintenant un an que j'étais
mineure quand on s'est connus non oui
c'est vrai ouais c'est pas demander
quand il a connu depuis quand tu lui est
fidèle
oui c'est vrai tu piques je travaille
très bien tu attends j'ai jamais eu le
temps d'être infidèle donc comme ça a
lancé au début c'était non alors parce
que vous n'avez pas travailler lorsque
vous étiez mineurs non je faisais des
études
ah oui mais alors côté vous avez fauté
moi et moi je ne ne faut qu'après des
études et après on s'est mariés donc ces
déplacés
quoi donc vous avez connu qu'un homme
dans votre vie nle quoi m l'ennemi elle
est sortie avec son mail espace juste
avant là c'était quoi la demie c'est
quand vous voulez tout savoir oui oui
quand j'ai passé mon baccalauréat
balma là dedans parce que la leçon alors
quand on me dit parler de force ça va
s'entendre à une action ce qui permet à
pas mal
alors c'est ce que vous allez faire et
les bricolages salle avec moi si je vous
le dis c'est très simple vous allez
fermer les yeux et une personne à vous
embrasser sur la bouche et vous allez
devoir deviner de qui le sépare d'accord
alors c'est bien parce qu'on rajeunisse
chez toi c'est vrai alors vous fermez
les yeux je vais choisir la personne
ouais ouais je choisis bien
[Musique]
alors c'est qui déjà j'ai senti de la
barbe alors je veux dire c'est qu'ils
cessaient pas et si point carton ses
vérités sur les bosseurs et ils sont
très très drôle merci d'être là aller il
ya camille combal qui arrive on
l'accueille
oui à nouveau jeu pour vous allez c'est
parti bocaly garder ses stars ça va pas
mais ça va je sais que ça ça va quoi il
n'a pas été vraiment il a l'air d'avoir
pris la mouche lui c'est quoi jma fait
trop de mal je te parle plus d'accord
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai préparé que oui
et non répond ce que je peux pas
bien qu'on verra plus comme ça donne un
ventilateur votre chronique voyage sans
il est pas très au point
je savais que réussir un beau livre et à
la salle n'avait pas vu sur les
ambitions
oui c'est sûr ça me rappelle quand on
avait fait les amours trop et tu t'es
trompé sur mobile
[Musique]